autre manifestation à paris cet après
midi cette fois contre les licenciements
et la réforme de l'assurance chômage
le cortège est parti du siège du medef
et devait rejoindre matignon mais
l'accès a été interdit par un arrêt
préfectoral des manifestants mobilisés
pour la deuxième fois à l'appel de la
cgt depuis france entreprise touchée par
un plan de licenciement qui concerne 600
salariés
un mouvement soutenu par des syndicats
d'autres secteurs comme l'hôtellerie
l'industrie ou encore le social mise en
péril par la crise sanitaire et ces
restrictions pour eux l'aide de l'état
apporté aux entreprises à favoriser la
précarité de l'emploi
si on veut y arriver pendant qu'on
arrive à tout ce sont donc on aimerait
déjà y ait du monde dans la rue et
ensuite à met ça sur le terrain
politique
parce que comme on dit beaucoup d'argent
qui est distribué aux patrons donc elle
tue pas on était sorti avec votre propre
argent et ça c'est intolérable
on voit bien que la crise permet à
certains de profiter de la période pour
licencier à tour de bras et c'est ça
qu'on dénonce en disant qu'il faut une
autre oeuvre une autre politique qui
justement soit pas d'aidé dagogo pour
une entreprise et qui derrière vont en
profiter
dix ans si ce qui me met en colère c'est
de leur dire écoutez vous êtes ces
entreprises vous les avez aidé vous les
avez été à s'installer vous leur avez
donné de l'argent de l'état notre argent
eh ben ça veut dire que si c'est sauter
des l'a ensuite elle elle dépose des
bilans alors qu'il n'y a aucun
l'argument et économique
ces sociétés là doivent rembourser et si
ce qui permettra peut-être d'indemniser
les salariés qui se font licence